foreign
Yang has kept us laughing for years on
Saturday Night Live and his appearance
on Weekend Update as the iceberg that
took down the Titanic may just be one of
his best what did the autopsy say they
Iceberg did no they drowned that's not
me
and the character was determined to
promote their song Loverboy wine me
dying me I had an early lunch but I'm
hungry for you
catching and who can forget when Bowen
portrayed a fitness instructor in Soul
cycle auditioning for a permanent
position on the coveted stationary bike
this morning I Googled racism and guess
what it bummed me out
and then I Googled gay racism and that
was even worse
some of his best work was done in pairs
like bonjour hi where Bowen and Kate
McKinnon played French Canadian news
reporters in Quebec we say tastes better
with the big old yes lick the cream
cheese out of the oven with shout outs
to Celine Dion and Drake We felt seen as
Canadians ah yes this is the part of the
show where we find out if you saw Drake
did you see drunk today
no this has been the Rick watch and
Bowen recently portrayed Aladdin's Jafar
taking aim at Florida's Don't Say Gay
Bell and Republican Governor Ron
DeSantis don't say gay well if there is
no gay there is no Disney and everyone
loves Disney including you because your
dumbass got married there
and that's the gayest thing you can do